i think i was so excited about
doing this with you because i mean for a
million reasons obviously
but what a huge part
of my history you played by being on the
cover of the issue of big brother
magazine
yeah which just fired up all this
controversy and for anybody who doesn't
know what big brother magazine is
this was a skateboarding magazine which
was for no purpose other than to just be
filthy inappropriate like just
bad you know like they just did all this
bad
[ __ ] and it was the people who ran big
brother magazine who went on to start
jackass
so this is like the origins of jackass
and
the cover of big brother that had
ryan sheckler on it how old were you
then i was eight
eight yeah was that your first front
cover that was my first cover
but like the fact that it was big
brother who was also run by hustler
magazine you know larry well no no but
that's the thing that was the
the it wasn't yet uh owned by larry
flynn oh it wasn't yet it wasn't and the
thing was big brother was all
controversial to begin with like they
had these articles on like the 10 most
effective ways to kill yourself and they
were
dead serious about it dude yeah i wasn't
allowed to read it
i wasn't around like at all allowed to
read anything
that was in that magazine i could look
at the cover and that was it
um even the covers were wildly
inappropriate but even even the magazine
you're on the cover of you
couldn't read no absolutely not no it
was all over the news like it was on the
news and it was like because
then the reporters started actually
reading the interview questions that
they were like asking these you know
i was the i don't think i was the
youngest there was like a six-year-old
and then it went up to like 13 and 14
but like
you know the 12 and 13 year olds are
asking them about like do you have pubic
hair yeah like
would you [ __ ] your mom yeah like if it
would magically make you a pro
skateboarder would you [ __ ] your own
mother
chris who knows dude it was just like
and so already big brother magazine was
in all kinds of trouble anyway
yeah but then when now they got the
[ __ ] kids it was called the kids
issue
yeah it's purely [ __ ] kids and
big brother's doing its thing so it's
all over the news there's all this
outrage
it was crazy there's so much controversy
in the media about big brother magazine
for the kids issue
that larry flint the famous pornographer
hustler magazine guy who's a big first
amendment dude
he was he heard a bit he says man i
[ __ ] dig this
so larry flint buys big brother magazine
now there's like 27 porno magazines
and one skateboard magazine like put out
by larry flint
yeah and um the the irony of it was that
before larry flint bought it it was
filled with
actual nudity all kinds of and then
at once larry flint bought it then uh
the no more nudity and it actually
cleaned it up a little bit that was a
rule
larry flint made like you know because
that's illegal
oh okay it was just a [ __ ] illegal
thing dude
and uh it was ryan's cover
ryan's issue got the attention of larry
flynn larry flint bought it became a
bigger
like more thing and then jackass started
because of that
wow all because of you ryan it was wild
man it's like the only time you could
ever get a melon grab
on the cover of a magazine and uh dude
it was eight years old man i had no idea
um but yeah dave carney and all the boys
yeah those wild times man yeah chris
norocco
did you see the the documentary about
big brother magazine
no i haven't seen it yet dude it's
[ __ ] crazy man
i i still haven't seen it where can you
see it it's on hulu it's called
dumb and it's uh the story of big
brother magazine and really what it is
is a jackass
origin story and the thing about jackass
is it's like kind of wholesome because
like
we don't we're not mean to anybody else
we only really do [ __ ] up [ __ ] to
ourselves like it's in a good spirit
but big brother magazine was not that
way dude and when i went to the premiere
for the dumb documentary like
it it [ __ ] shook me up
i was like i was like dude you put that
whole story all into one documentary and
it's like
upsetting how [ __ ] awful it was
it's just bad [ __ ] not a good spirit all
bad things
yeah dude